hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play and need you Justine okay got
my super sturdy thing here I actually
jumped ahead of it but um it was just
two more barrels and all I did was I put
the broken ladder there up there I did I
went ahead himself alright yeah moving
on I don't know how to save that guy
down there but huh whatever I guess
he'll be ok if I don't kill him maybe
there's a key I can go back and get it I
don't know huh what the hell good good
good
hahaha guy okay yeah yeah get on your
good good good eye Oh what was that huh
let's take a ladder couldn't I just get
the letter ha ha I don't know I don't
know I don't know are not crawling how
can monsters be in here Oh cockroaches
are cockroaches I don't have any oil oh
I don't like this I don't like this I
don't like crawling and confined spaces
oh man oh man oh god a dead end a dead
end uh Shh [ __ ] oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy I wonder if there's
like an equivalent for the darkness in
this game as opposed to the last game oh
boy oh boy oh boy okay going down okay I
guess I just I guess I got it
Oh Darrin it okay hello
so cylinder the photograph what year is
this
I don't even know I thought I thought
like you know won't budge of course it's
boarded up I thought like being um the
original amnesia it was like before the
phonograph or at least earlier than that
oh oh oh
creepy drawings oh man not as creepy as
that Alexander photo but still pretty
creepy okay what about here many
Parisians gathers a violin virtuoso malo
I heard that name before
visibly intoxicated
monsieur de vue de da silva i lower
us-ally that's the guy who may be a
other no okay all right what do we got
here
torture device ooh Frankie Frank come
here come here
that's right don't know what I'm doing
maybe I got a crush something to get the
juices out of it probably probably
that's how these games work lots of
things I got a crush to get the juice
out of a hammer cutie
Oh give me him Oh give me a hammer darn
it it's okay
probably just go through the guy anyway
like it did before
okay still no oil Lisa place is brightly
lit um oh don't okay
is there anything else a like a lot of
nothing just to get to here whatever
whatever I don't know the downstairs
library still reminded her of father all
those hours spent spend there had
fostered a sense of shelter I would have
thought that they would have been able
to spell check this okay
Oh Oh mannequins mannequins mannequins
medicate Anakin's don't like mannequins
hello fine it's brick shows into your
spiritual sighs Oh No Oh father used to
say there were no right answers
I would like to guide you half the light
guide me okay all right
however a dark tender boxers tinderboxes
I don't know about torchy doodad
does this slide - um I'm not gonna waste
it there's nothing else in here
oh what's it coming come here smash
nothing oh man that that did not do well
for my sanity
okay um what's in here
denna box nope tests have been going
well most long-term the light box having
Justine to the slide
oh the slides I'm picking up okay
definitely read things into the flight I
enough foreseen effort lira deuce all
her experiences into one of the four
character slices okay she doesn't seem
to fully understand what I'm asking more
difficult as she tends to always choose
to sides with characters facing the same
way okay I don't probably clue I'm too
stupid to figure it out ten bucks 50
bucks
finally maybe some way to get light
because it is dark in here okay hello
alright what we got why do we got let's
see um
holy dope hello can't hide from me oh
I'm so great anything else
is that it that was it darn yet give me
more tinderbox free at least give me oil
uh
all right yeah what's this hello hello
sir look like a gentleman madam
Mademoiselle hey are you with weight you
look very similar said a your mother
mother today I played outside with
klaris saw bird pick at a snail blah
blah blah bird talk of on the air today
I was one with open arms but today I was
the right one what but I played with the
slides from father's lightbox above all
I like the man standing on to the right
father asked why I said he sees things
he likes
today I was the right one father said I
picked the wrong slide yesterday when I
made the chambermaid cry he wanted me to
pick one with the sword while I picked
the man on the right I never picked the
one with the sword never picked the one
with sword okay these are clues haha I
can figure this out these are clues
today I was the one kneeling aged 11
today father came for me in my room
still couldn't look him in the eyes he
said I should feel shame shouldn't feel
ashamed and that I only try to fill the
void left by mother when he was looking
I took this star stone from his
collection only try okay Adam I was the
one with a sword I don't know oh hello
I'm here hello bunk you
ah don't start spitting fire at me buddy
this imagine definitely like fire shoot
now oh sorry sorry buddy
sorry okay I'm not gonna pull any more
levers cuz if there's a live guy
somewhere it levers him kill him okay
sorry sorry sorry buddy
sorry sorry about that um oh we got here
oh the lovely no okay um haha okay here
no okay no this is oh hello
okay that did something Oh Oh slides
haha slides oh uh swords so I guess it
was that number to whatever man's arms
opened think I read the kneeling one
kneeling okay and then this would be the
one on the right when facing to the
right he's not on the right okay um do I
got to put him in in the right order or
something I don't know combination does
not work uh these pictures there's four
paintings on the wall ah go away uh I
don't think they there's a guy kneeling
guy with arms open I guess technically
um I don't know oh no no I'm so bad with
puzzles why do they give me puzzles I
don't know I don't know dude I'm sorry
bro man dude some wine cool off oh I'm
so bad at puzzle holes so bad I'm so bad
I'm so bad
ah get out of here door man Oh bring it
on bring it up or get on what do you got
huh huh huh why can't I move click okay
that's a bad idea
that's a bad idea all right
oh man do I have a note diamond note no
mementos fantastic ah soul journal
entries okay hmm today black I don't
know I don't know using the puzzle lock
has proven more difficult as she tends
to always choose two slides with
characters facing the same way okay I
don't know I've asked her why this is
but she doesn't seem to flee okay
so I have to get people the slides that
are facing the same way okay
so the one on the right uh
Kaleigh try this again okay it was like
this huge she never picked the guy with
a sword and the scour the sword is
facing the same direction as the guy
with arms open so kneeling and the right
one she said she liked the right one
okay so so 4 & 3 4 & 3 okay put it ha ha
ha
tell me what to do tell me tell me your
secrets ah it was behind the baby maybe
we can move one of these nope no oh not
even close
alright I'm gonna cut it here and I'm
gonna figure out this puzzle in the
meantime but thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
part bye bye